[Music]
all week we've been marking the release
of Mission Impossible dead reckoning
part one with many of the film stars
including one of the franchise's most
popular characters on Monday Tony and I
spoke to Simon Pigg who played Ethan
Hunt's right-hand man Benji Dunn and
five Mission Impossible movies here's
our interview with him starting with the
clip of Benji leading Tom Cruise's Ethan
into one of the most exciting and
dangerous action scenes of the entire
series
I must have made a wrong turn somewhere
no no that's it that's it why how could
this be it well you can see the train
right
yes I see the train what about it and
you have a parachute had a parachute
who do you expect me to do well just you
know
jump just
doesn't work like that I'm not that high
there's there's Ledges sticking out
everywhere I'm gonna hit them before the
parachute even opens even if I could get
the parachute open I don't know if I can
make it across the valley and intercept
the land safely on a moving train
I copy look I'm just trying to help you
okay I need you to take a step back and
pull yourself together because I am
under a lot of pressure right now
Mission Impossible is from Paramount
Pictures part of the same company as CBS
and the legendary Simon Peg joins us
right now how you doing hi fellas I'm
really good I'm very very happy good
thank you for subscribe to a very bad
day there you were having your character
having an okay
yeah no doubt about it and and that
scene comes right before Tom's big
motorcycle jump yeah take us on the set
that day was it as chaotic as it seemed
it actually was the opposite of chaos
really Tom is very very diligent when it
comes to preparing for these things he's
not crazy everyone says oh he must be
crazy he does you know but he trains
hard everything is in place it's a
well-oiled machine we were up there just
to see it I was doing my off lines for
the bit when he comes to the edge and
then we stayed up to watch it happen and
it was day one you know day one of the
shoot day one and you could either see
that as us sort of like starting as we
mean to go on you know set the standard
or just in case it doesn't work we don't
have to shoot a whole load of the film
and then stop this is your friend and
your colleague many years now yeah what
was it like seeing him go
it was scary we were all a bit
hysterical because I mean we trust him
and we trust the system We Trust
everything involved it's not like you
know the the sort of uncertainty is
minimal but still it's it's
nerve-wracking and he would disappear
and then we'd wait and there'd be a big
sort of pause and then you'd hear a good
canopy which meant his shoot had opened
at least yeah still had to get down to
the bottom so it was yeah it was
exhilarating to say the least well you
actually did pull out your phone
yeah so what was going through your mind
as he was toppling over I was I was
looking at movie history being it was
movie history right this is the biggest
stunt not only in the franchise but one
of the biggest stunts in movie history
you know and so I thought I better
capture this for posterity and um and in
case the other cameras fail we have one
shot we got it on the iPhone don't worry
guys I got it I got it on the phone yeah
yeah yeah it's great oh man so you were
you came into the mission impossible
franchise uh at the mi4 or my three mi3
wow that's a long time ago it was and he
was a kind of lab technician at the time
and JJ Abrams had called me I thought it
was a nice little Cameo I was gonna have
a little you know I'd go in Hollywood
and then I go home to my dogs and
everything will go back to normal but
here we are five films later so I know
you're working with a script uh but then
you have these scenes like there's one
you're dismantling a bomb wall like toss
it off one liners I've got two buddies
high stakes how much of that is
predetermined and you're just delivering
the line and how much room is there for
you to just have fun because you know
these people oh yeah yeah well Chris
McCrory is is always really Keen for us
to to invest ourselves in the characters
and to to throw stuff in
and he's an oscar-winning writer so we
the script is amazing but there's always
room in the moment to kind of Chuck in
little asides and you know I mean you
never know what you'd be doing what
you'd be saying when you're diffusing a
a an artificially intelligent nuclear
bomb so yeah in the moment things come
up you know that you throw in I want to
ask you about the villain because it's a
little unusual yeah villain in this
movie how would you describe well when I
was told about the idea of this this
entity this sort of self-aware kind of
computer program that that uh Eastside
Morales are brilliant sort of like human
villain is is working at the behest of I
thought that sounds very Mission
Impossible it's a bit sci-fi Mission has
always been about new technology and but
in the time since we started shooting to
now the notion of AI has become more and
more prominent in our sort of social
discussions and it feels incredibly
pressing there speaking of existential
threats potential Mission Impossibles
you're on strike right now uh with the
writers yes uh there's a possibility
that the actors may go on strike yeah
they're not too distant future
these things need to be worked out or
there is no more Hollywood there's no
more entertainment exactly what are your
thoughts in general uh on the strikes
well things need to be fair you know
things need to be Equitable and the the
infrastructure needs to be adapted to
accommodate the new the new ways we
watch film and TV streaming and you know
the tech companies need to understand
that that
for things to continue everyone needs to
be treated fairly and as soon as that
gets sorted out and it it will do
hopefully things will be okay but we
can't face another
content drought next year you know we've
only just got back on our feet where
everyone's only just back in the cinema
if everyone's next year is ready to go
and there's nothing to watch that's
that's going to be a terrible thing so
we need to just talk sensibly and get it
all sorted out I'm curious to get your
opinion on movie making filmmaking and
also artificial intelligence you know
when we keep it in the back of our mind
what's going on with the writers
the only thing AI can do is create
mediocrity because all it can do is
aggregate what's out there so it yes it
can write a script but it'll be rubbish
you know what I mean AI has had no
childhood trauma ai's never had a
boyfriend or a girlfriend never had
heartbroken you're spot on it's never
been through anything that would give it
the the the impetus to create art when
it has its own personality and its own
experiences it can write a film about
what it's like to have nobody but at the
moment it can't do that and so to rely
on it would be to just make everything
mediocre and what we have to fight
mediocrity in order to create great art
I know that sounds lofty no no that
might be one of the best answers I've
ever heard yeah that's the idea of AI
hey Simon Pegg we appreciate you joining
us you're one of the most versatile
thank you so much good luck moving
forward lovely to be here thank you
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one is in theaters now go see